le médecin fait l'échographie et parle
pas trop mais ça c'est toujours un peu
habituelle et moi j'essaie de faire des
blagues pour comprendre un peu parce
qu'elle parlait de moins en moins et moi
j'essaie de me rassurer de plus en plus
et je veux qu'on se rappellera toute
notre vie tout moment là et comme tous
les parents qui ont sur de nouvelles à
ce moment là elle a juste dit ok et là
moi je me rappelle j'ai pleuré juste
quand elle a dit ok je savais qu'elle un
problème un papa juste un petit problème
un énorme problème est que c'était que
tout en train de s'effondrer par là j'ai
tout compris
chaque année de plus en plus de parents
décident d'aller jusqu'au terme de la
grossesse alors qu'une maladie est
détectée au stade de l'embryon ou du
foetus en 2010
9808 grossesse ont été poursuivis alors
qu'elle aurait pu justifier une
interruption médicale de grossesse ce
chiffre ne s'élevait qu'à 5 121 en 2008
il y a deux ans paul et sarah ont été
confrontés à cette douloureuse question
je savoure à notre mariage je suis
tombée enceinte c'est un peu comme un
cadeau qu'on refait on est en été super
super contents tous les deux tout se
passait bien pour nous et les coquilles
écoute du cinquième mois
c'est là où on aura besoin d'eux on nous
a expliqué que notre fille avait une
malformation très graves qui lui
permettrait pas de vivre en tout cas
peut-être que quelques jours sur terre
dont ils ont
orienté la matière aussi bas en fait on
va avoir un petit enfant etc mais on
sait très bien qu'il va pas vivre très
longtemps sauf calmer car on arrive
hélas une pose un dilemme ici assez
différent on arrive dans cette salle
d'échographie beaucoup de parents vivent
ça enfin tous les parents un peu sombre
sauf que là il ya quatre médecins à la
place d'un médecin donc on nous explique
anne ont même pas du tout votre enfant
va pas du tout mourir c'est un enfant
viable aucun problème sauf que par
contre il a un très très lourd handicap
c'est donc un spina bifida
myéloméningocèle il ya plusieurs formes
de spina bifida ça peut aller une forme
bénigne ou un enfant
presque d'avoir à une forme un peu plus
grave et on sait que notre fille avait
une forme assez évoluée de ce handicap
ce handicap lui permettrait pas de
marché il peut y avoir aussi des
déficiences mentales donc ils permettent
pas forcément d'aller à l'école comme
les autres voilà ça c'est notamment
cesser ces diagnostics qu'on nous avait
expliqué le toi tu es avec le ventre nu
devant quatre médecins tu es tu pleures
28 août a pu tellement de démériter à ce
moment là et on fait une liste de tout
de tout ce qui va se passer de tout de
tout la future vie ils veulent vraiment
de faire comprendre le réel voix et l'ol
qui est dur parce que là ce dont on
parle c'est la question de garder ou pas
donc c'est à ce moment là qu'on que la
possibilté deuxième geste est proposé
donc j'essaie l'interruption médicale de
grossesse et dans le cas de notre fille
on pouvait arrêter la grossesse si on
voulait ou continuer et à partir de ce
moment là il nous présente les options
tu me faisais les médecins aient percé
des parents qui avaient décidé de garder
leurs enfants jusqu'à présent à leur vie
de trois ans après la naissance de leur
enfant handicapé à une des penan dit
qu'ils étaient très difficiles où
quasiment tous les couples 70% divorce
on a trop de chance parce que parce
qu'on était d'accord moi ya plusieurs
personnes qui m'ont dit ça aurait été
chaude de faire ce choix en couple
effectivement c'est vrai que pour être
d'accord là dessus c'est compliqué quoi
un parent qui va s'occuper de l'enfant
et l'eau doit être plus en retrait ça
veut dire qu'il ya aussi un parent qui
va pas bosser parce qu'en fait c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de temps à l'hôpital
c'est beaucoup de temps avec les kinés
avec temps voilà tout tout tout comme
initial qui souffrent de ton argent et
donc voilà ça veut dire une vie
personnelle que tu dis à ton enfant quoi
ils me disent bon il ya aussi la
possibilité d'arrêter et en fait ça on
passe très vite dessus il n'y a personne
qui sort de l'hôpital et qui peut se
dire on continue avec tout ce qu'on le
dépeint c'est pas possible de dire
attends mais c'est une super bonne idée
on va évidemment qu'on va pas arrêter sa
vie et la première chose dont on a
eu envie en sortant de l'hôpital c'était
je me rappelle c'était un peu prendre un
énorme bol d'air frais d'herbe d'amour
tout ce qu'on pourrait faire avec elle
tout ce qu'on pourrait mettre en place
ça on n'en avait pas parlé évidemment
avec le médecin ce que c'est pas leur
rôle guillaume g jusqu'à présent on
s'était jamais dit je vais faire un
choix dans ma vie mais moi j'étais un
peu angoissée elle vit au choix là il
est complètement malade quoi et du coup
je me dis vraiment que je prenne en
compte les deux les deux choix quoi et
en moi je m'étais presque convaincu de
me dire ouais dans la mer solution bâle
a
vu ce qu'on nous a décrit vu
vu toutes les inconnues quoi peut-être
que vraiment le choix d'arrêter c'est
peut-être le mieux quoi et puis c'est
pas y avait toujours un truc au fond de
moi qui me retenait tous et à l'afrique
tiendra enfin moi j'avais dû dire ça
c'était ok moi je
aujourd'hui contenu et moi je me
rappelle que j'ai écrit une lettre que
j'ai mis dans sa poche quand il est
parti au boulot le lundi pas voulu dire
ça va aller en fait on va continuer en
fait on va la rendre demain que ça vit
ça va être génial en fait en fait c oupe
steam tarifs peut-être aujourd'hui
continuer je crois et puis on va et puis
on va faire on va faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour pour que pour ça le mieux
possible c'était ce à quoi c'est ça
l'idée qu on cherche toujours un peu d'
aventure d'un audi là on l'avait en
plein dans la phase on ne peut pas vous
pouvez pas dire non à ça c'était une
sorte d' aventure un peu compliqué voilà
mais en même temps c'est ça c'est ça la
vie quoi mais effectivement je pense que
ça a été dur à un moment de se dire on
pense aussi à la possibilité de lier mg
et heureusement qu'on n'y a pensé et
heureusement qu'on s'est dit que c'était
possible après on a vraiment choisi et
on sait pourquoi on a choisi bah ouais
c'est ce à quoi c'est une aventure dans
ta tête pas choisi cette aventure lot
peut-être plus barrés dans l'himalaya ou
quoi mais ouais c'est enfin ça fait
partie de la vie ce soit là on la pose
et librement avec toutes les
informations que nous venons et les
médecins et parce que nous on a aussi
réussi à prendre du recul pendant ce
week-end est donc ce choix là on l'a
posé en pleine confiance quoi en fait
c'est superstition faire un choix quoi
en fait c'est un chose ici en plus mais
en fait
cette liberté quoi ce que tu dis moi
voilà tout ce qu'on a pu voir avancer
vers la cua donc on y va quoi et puis où
est ce qu'ils disent assez ou tuteurs
permission quoi
on ne devrait pas arrêter sa vie parce
qu'en fait la société permet pas de
l'accueillir bien en fait pas elle de ne
pas vivre c'est plutôt à la société de
s'adapter à tous ces enfants là qui ont
des handicaps qui sont là en fait ils
ont le droit de vivre comme les autres
avec le même confort ça pour améliorer
la vie de notre fils a subi une
opération il ya eu des complications
très graves après après l'opération le
moment un peu vraiment beaucoup trop
critique où je risquais de mourir et ma
fille aussi ils ont tout arrêté ils
m'ont fait accoucher en urgence sans
césarienne je n'ai pas vu ma fille
pendant 24 heures et moi je peux aller
voir quoi en fait c'était un moment un
peu difficile parce que non paul a
rencontré anna tout seul moi je me
rappelle la première fois que j'ai vu
annassers sur mon téléphone palm a
envoyé des vidéos tu apprends les petits
gestes eu lui laver les yeux
la bouche avec des toute petite lingette
était toute petite couche
on n'avait pas vraiment les droits que
les parents ont normalement sur leurs
enfants ils peuvent le prendre avant
bras les nourrir elle était très belle
et elle avait des petits doigts collés
je me rappelle et moi par contre j'étais
sûr qu'elle allait vivre
est en fait au bout de quatre jours ils
nous ont dit que ça allait plus du tout
et qu'elle en fait elle n'arrivait plus
à s'accrocher elle
elle respirait très mal à ce moment-là
ça s'appelait vraiment de l'acharnement
thérapeutique on est en train de faire
on a passé toutes les dernières heures
avec à la partie en ce moment là et on
l'a accompagné
jusqu'à sa mort
enfin la prendre dans nos bras et c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment impressionnant
et puis tu sens que moi c'est une petite
boule de tu as une petite boule de bois
d'amour quoi et ça c'est particulier
parce qu'en fait il dit voilà je suis
censée célébrer un peu la vie en fait tu
dis moi tu célèbres que ça mais tu
prépares savoir en fait un vécu une vie
très condensé de quatre jours cinq jours
on essayait de de vivre du coup cette
vie avec elle plus fort possible que ce
n'est pas possible je sais pas on essaie
de tout faire pour les met encore plus
fort que ce qu'on pouvait je me suis moi
tant il faut qu'elles connaissent à peu
commencé dehors tu vois qu'on dit plus
quand il fait froid à tous à quilmes
digigram souffre et à lui souffler de
sur le visage tuant au moins qu'elles
sentent comme la chanter une petite
chanson au pour les errements au moins
tu auras entendu tout ça elle avait vécu
la plus belle vie qu'elle pouvait avoir
que que de l'amour
d'élite d'amour des infirmières qui
était incroyable qui s'occupait d'elle
de manière tellement douce on n'aurait
même pas pu rivaliser laquelle est et
nous qui lui donnions l'eau plus
d'amants possible et et voilà et c'était
sa vie et je pense que il n'y avait pas
beaucoup qui vivent des vielles aussi
belle ça apprend à être humble devant la
nature et devant ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle nous donne et on n'y peut rien
on a juste à accepter et de cette
manière là c'est
c'est difficile mais
les c'est possible
mais le sens de l'histoire c'est juste
qu'on est content d'avoir vécu ça quoi
quand on est heureux de l'avoir vécu
avec elle
elle n'est pas là pour elle et palabres
nous dira si elle est rose ou pas
[Musique]